[Musique]
chaque jour on dénombre environ 15
millions de déplacements en région
parisienne les personnes qui n'habitent
pas à proximité de leur lieu de travail
met en moyenne une heure pour rejoindre
leur domicile soit pour l'ensemble des
parisiens 3 milliards d'eur parle de
deux choses l'une ou les villes sont
trop petites ou bien il ya trop de
voitures
la seconde affirmation paraît plus
vraisemblable les villes sont
embouteillées sans arêtes conséquences
perte de temps énervement et somnolence
une somnolence qui peut ne pas être ému
mais à quoi peut bien rêver un
automobiliste à la petite reine des
suites des encombrements
qu'à cela ne tienne pied-à-terre le
trottoir lui n'est pas surchargé
[Musique]
et le rêve continue et le cycliste aussi
et lui arrivera bien avant vous à
destination une objection le standing
vous ne vous voyez pas arrivant au
bureau sur une bicyclette ou chevauchant
un vélomoteur
mais je parle trop poursuivez votre rêve
[Musique]
lorsque vous serez réveiller et si vous
n'êtes pas convaincu nous ferons un
petit calcul
quel est le prix de revient moyen de
votre automobile prix d'achat de la
voiture
12000 prix d'achat de l'assurance 800
enfants la vignette 120
la carte grise sans fond l'entretien 400
francs par an les contraventions 30
francs le sabot de denvers 50 francs
environ
le plein d'essence par mois 40 france
est un minimum au total quinze mille
francs soit 3000 à 5000 francs par an
pour votre voiture
alors votre voiture vous est-elle
vraiment ici
ceci est un moyen ingénieux mais plus
rationnelle les solutions éventuelles
sérieuses sont tout d'abord les
transports en commun comme le
métropolitain les lignes de banlieue
ligne de saw her verts etc
chaque jour trois mille six cents trains
sont mis à la disposition des voyageurs
soit environ un million deux cent mille
places le prix de revient des transports
en commun est d'environ 1200 francs par
an soit le tiers et dépenses engendrées
par l'automobile
[Musique]
cousin germain du train l'autobus dont
le prix de revient est le même que celui
du métro parisien
exception faite bien sûr pour les lignes
de banlieue
troisième solution le taxi mais d'un
prix de revient plus élevé il offre les
mêmes inconvénients de circulation que
l'automobile personnes
quatrième solution les parkings ils
permettent à l'automobiliste de garer sa
voiture et de se rendre à son lieu de
travail par un moyen de transport en
commun au choix du gain de temps et
problèmes de stationnement résolu
plusieurs tarifs selon les endroits 1/2
francs les quatre première heures 1
francs de l'heure où deux francs de
l'heure
[Musique]
la cinquième et dernière solution n'en
est encore qu'au stade de l'expérience à
montpellier dans la ville sont répartis
150 véhicules du même type pour utiliser
ces voitures il suffit de souscrire à un
abonnement qui vous donne droit à
recevoir une clé pouvant ouvrir
n'importe laquelle des 150 euros un
changement rapide de conducteur peut
donc être effectué pour faire démarrer
la voiture
il faut vous être muni préalablement
d'un jeton en vente dans les bureaux de
tabac
arrivés à destination vous retirer votre
jetons qu'il vous faut changer s'il est
usé le prix de revient est pour le
moment de 50 centimes du kilo mais
principal avantage des places réservées
sont aménagés dans la ville donc plus de
problème de stationnement sationnement
qui vous cause souvent bien du trac
alors pourquoi ne pas essayer une des
quelques solutions que nous avons
proposé perte de temps mais gain
d'argent perte d'argent mais gain de
temps ou bien tout simplement perte de
temps et perd peu d'argent à vous de
choisir
bloqués comme vous l'êtes dans cet
embouteillage
vous aurez tout le temps de faire votre
choix alors bon courage
[Musique]